once everything was awesome
now everything okay Lucy I brought you
coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh Ness
did I interrupt you brooding just now
first of all I know you have said that
this is unlike voicing other characters
you actually act stuff out in the booth
yes like you get thrown down but some
sort of like love you know sort of how
does that the performance well it's a
very big physical movie that's not like
people sitting at desks or in chairs
yeah they're doers Lucy's a master
builder she's flying her through the air
they're on spaceships they gotta go to
the star system they got to get through
you know the top like there's so much
going on so what's fun about doing the
voices you want to bring all that
physicality I mean it's not not just
this this is the old instruments right
so that's why I throw myself around
while I'm doing it I mean I look like a
crazy person do you do the same but I
feel like it works you know there's
something very freeing about not about
knowing that you're not being filmed
because because I saw the YouTube videos
oh yeah they might be doing some
behind-the-scenes stuff in those moments
but if you think those are big just uses
a fly on the wall when we're not being
filmed because you know inherently when
you know your face is a prop you're
going to be a little restrained in what
you allow your face to do but when you
know that it's not you can really
enunciate and just stick you late and be
really big and and turn your body and do
all this stuff that cameraman will be
like come on bro let's act like you're
so I know um Chris and Phil have said
that Rex is modeled after sort of you're
going from basically I'm at this guy to
this superhero right you know kind of
like action hero that you've booked off
right so what does that say like what
are they trying to tell you do they
think you're cooler now and do you and
which which side do you tend to veer
towards on your career yeah
yeah well it's funny it's a good
question
first of all I think they mind from my
career like they do everything from
everything that lives in the zeitgeist
yeah because it's relevant and because
people know about it and because it's
funny and so first and foremost they're
getting laughs but I think what they're
ultimately the message is not so much
about what they think of me but what
they think about young kids who aspire
to be macho and tough and sometimes do
so at the expense of who they really are
such an answer I know you're still
having at hard yeah do you ever see the
wreck side yeah I I think he's like 7030
Emmett to Rex
percent of it with a little 30 percent
nice little balance can you have more 13
voices really quickly basically I'm
asking for a demonstration you want one
yeah yeah I can do it where yo we know I
go I'm here with Nicky Novak from
Fandango shut up kid here you're here
with Nicky
Tomac from Fandango I'm mcqueen whatever
I would not be I'm getting super evil
vibes here I could change my form to
something else if this makes you
uncomfortable hey guys they'll go back
don't worry is much more palatable baby
yeah but you two had how did you guys
have so much chemistry when I don't even
think you recorded together
no that's the directors that's just
excellent crew you know they knew and
then the you can't deny the universe
won't be denied let me be sure yes okay
agreed the two of you together are magic
yeah I think so too
I asked her projected so his dreams
often to get into his subconscious to
you you really am what does he dream
about well girl it's pretty dark
[Laughter]
I know Kristen Phil have modeled
characters in this film after real-life
personalities and your queen whatever
you want to be so was that modeled after
you and if you could be whatever you
want it to be for a day either of you
what would you be well I think it was
modeled after me I'm gonna say I'm gonna
be narcissistic as they do it it's all
about me they thought they saw me and
they said that's who she has to be and I
said okay
and if I could be anything for a day any
anything or anyone for a shift into
whatever you want
shucks happy a unicorn see that wasn't
so bad nothing got in
welcome to the CAF what has to join Oh
mom word - how incredible I mean when I
read over the IMDB page and I see just
Jason Momoa say might get excited do you
have a favorite superhero in general I
mean you mean like in the world of
superheroes I think you can cross me
press 2d I mean I'll say let's say in
the Lego world I can the character of
Lucy is one of my favorite characters
ever created I think um the first movie
did such a good job of sort of saying oh
do you think you know what the female
characters in an animated movie are
supposed to be guess what and then the
Lego series exactly I love it so I know
Chris and Phil tend to model characters
after real-life personalities for this
film so it always happened with actors
usually you're playing totally different
characters every single time yeah they
talk to you about I mean you're this
you're sweet and that you know like is
there did they tell you why they cast
you in this and did you help shape that
character I hope that I helped you it's
very very flattering to think that they
listen getting cast and this is like
insanely dream come true yes I'm not
gonna lie I'm sitting here in this room
with you right now doing this interview
I cannot believe my back same I'm
flabbergasted
right so collaborating them with with
them in any way shape or form is
incredible the the thing that I got told
a lot in this process was more do more
of that try more of that and that really
fun because they are such collaborative
and creative filmmakers that I think the
thing that they are searching for always
is like authenticity yeah any character
that they write a new story right but
unlike at voicing other characters where
you stand in a booth you actually they
make you act it out yeah do and you give
me a little demonstration of how that
worked well like for me for general
mayhem it was a lot of standing with my
feet like really why are my hands on
hips and like this dress today is like
kind of a good example of like how I
felt in that character which you had a
lot of dish a lot doing a lot of this
you know like it was very physical it's
always our own physical process with
them you created this character of racks
which is basically Emmett's alter kind
of alter ego based on Chris's sort of
ascent to fame yes correct becoming this
big hero but you guys are Oscar nominees
so how Rex are you two now oh yeah golly
we're getting Rexy er and right now
we're thrilled you know that the Spider
Man resonated with audiences in a way
that you know surprised us in a great
way and the coolest part is watching you
know people launch it with their kids
and the kids look up at them and say
that he looks like me or they speak
Spanish like we do or I want to be like
her when I grow up like that very simple
thing that turned out to be really
powerful and were just really it makes
us feel really good so speaking of Chris
he said Elizabeth agreed that he's about
Chris as a person is about 70% Emmett
now and about 30% Rex I think that's a
good that's a great balance he's still
strong and can I do you know lift heavy
I still it hard yes he's still the same
genuine guy winning of him many many
years ago he still hasn't lost that pure
innocent side of himself but he's also
super hunky and cool and savvy yeah yeah
yeah and self-possessed I mean it goes
without saying obviously but you know
but you love a guy that like is in it
for the right reasons and even though
you know he's we've all seen a lot of
things that we didn't want to have to
see and that guy is still choosing to be
a positive force in the world
that's what we hope we can all do and
Tiffany adding Tiffany to the yes and
queen and I asked her because you guys
tend to model these characters somewhat
after people's personality yeah I feel
like so Queen whatever you want to be
wouldn't like was that based on
Tiffany's personality or is that
certainly that that buoyancy and joy
that she brings to it and her like
quickness and and and over-the-top gusto
that she brings seemed like it was such
a fun opportunity for the animators like
turned her into whatever she sounded
like at that moment and to and and she
was just so much fun to work with in
that in the booth because you could just
give her a little topic and she could
just go off and take it to crazy places
and me so much joy so if there's a movie
that you guys could remake as a lego
movie I feel like every movie should be
a starring role
starting at AFI 100 starting with
Citizen Kane to work our way down the
list that's yes yes what absolute list
of all it would be a heck of a lot
easier to write these things yes we
didn't have to write them ourselves we
could just we could literally just shop
is associate producer fantastic
graduation I love this I want to know
I'm a huge fan of Jason Momoa me too
he's had such an Aquaman he's the
sensation tell me a little Momoa moment
of having him at there on set in the
well the guy is just psyched it's
trapping is not an act we yeah we met
him at a Comic Con or like this guy is
so charismatic and so just like he's the
real deal that guy and we're like we got
to put him in the movie he'll be so fun
to have him in the movie and he was
excited to do it and and I loved that he
could crush me with his bare hands
what is more noble than the mark of a
real code we'll help me rescue my
friends anywhere near that system only
the toughest you're gonna get out of
there alive so congratulations on an
incredible movie thank you thank you I
am a most jealous you had all of those
superheroes all of those incredible
actors together or not together but in
the voice booth with you can you just
brag a little bit about pretty cool
pretty cool yeah Jason who plays that
Aquaman that was me he was ready to make
kind of himself Jason Jason yeah j-dog
yeah we Bruce Willis was pretty cool
revealing best I know it's on IMDB but I
don't remember we're all huge fans yeah
and we're huge fans of diehards so and
these characters are always sneaking
through air ducts so we're like in there
absolutely so I know Elizabeth's talked
about this is not a traditional when you
voice a movie typically you're standing
in a booth and you're saying she said
you guys get them down on the floor you
make them actually act it out you know
why is that and how does it make the
performance better well it's an
animation sometimes the directors are in
the recording booth we get in there with
the actors and
yeah we've got the funniest best improv
actors of all time in this movie so just
to not take advantage of that is insane
right I mean it makes it feel more real
when you're in the booth with them and
you're there playing off of you you're
playing off of them I mean it just feels
more real rather than being behind a
glass wall and just speaking into a
microphone any particularly insane
moments you can recall all of them yeah
have you seen the film with insane
moments but yeah it's it's it's really
fun because when we record with the
actor you know we're always following
the script and then we just throw it
away and stand there all really game to
be playful and that comes across in
their character like they bring so much
funny lines and extra bits of their
characters like oh yeah it's like a gift
it's three Wonder Woman's yeah because
why not and there are all different
types of Legos so there's DUPLO Wonder
Woman a friend's dog Wonder Woman and a
minifig Wonder Woman so we were like
this little girl has no rules why not
throw all the Wonder women from the
different kids into one world and you
told me you're a Wonder Woman want to be
oh yeah I would love to be why Wonder
Woman
why wonder what she's the coolest hero
of all time and she's got a rope of
truth so I would love to use that in
Hollywood oh my god to find out what
people are really thinking dangerous
what's your favorite character in the
film yeah I would say the Queen is my
favorite I mean she was such a challenge
to animate but it was such a joy to
anime having a shape-shifting character
that is a different form in every scene
yeah is a challenge story wise as well
but it was just such a joy to work with
the animators to really come up with her
charming character and I know Kristen
Phil always come up with these meta
references and there's so many like I
you know obviously there's a Back to the
Future reference in here Hot Tub Time
Machine yeah it was fantastic did you
villain someone that you particularly
threw in there
your own that was your one that was your
particular favorite I thought it was
cool to see the Wizard of Oz characters
were just in there for one shot kind of
fun
my favorite was Ruth Bader Ginsburg I
mean have like a strong female character
in there that you know you wouldn't
expect to see of dancing at a wedding I
mean and now she's a toy she's a toy
with a little tiny gap she's your
approval and she did that she was into
it yeah she was like why not be a lego
toy she's done it why not
you